Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestish, toil, tears and sweat. And of course, 45 minutes of podcasting gold. The words of Winston Churchill, spoken on the floor of the House of Commons on the 13th of May 1940. The Nazi war machine was on the march. France faced collapse under the impact of the German blitzkrieg. The British
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestish，辛劳、泪水与汗水。当然，还有45分钟的播客精华。这是温斯顿·丘吉尔于1940年5月13日在下议院发表的演讲。纳粹战争机器正在进军。法国在德国闪电战的冲击下濒临崩溃。英国
expeditionary force retreated to the beach at Dunkirk, surrounded and desperate. The little ships were on their way. Hitler was beginning the preparations for Operation Sealer. Dominic, calm down! The invasion of Britain. Britain stood alone and saved the world.
远征军撤退到敦刻尔克的沙滩上，被包围且陷入绝望。小船正在赶来的路上。希特勒开始为“海狮计划”做准备。多米尼克，冷静点！入侵英国。英国孤军奋战，拯救了世界。
You know this story better than you know your own names. 1940, perhaps the most consequential, most romanticised, perhaps most mythologised year in recent history. So welcome to The Rest is History. Sometimes we take a wide and rigorous perspective when we look at the history of China or Persia. Sometimes we narrow our focus to a single year, 1940s we're doing now, and indulge in some of these myths or perhaps debunk them. So today we're going to be joined by Tom's brother, James Holland, as if one Holland is not enough. James has written extensively about 1940s, written countless books about the Second World War. And he also presents our brilliant sister podcast, our little sister podcast, as Tom and I like to call it. We Have Ways of Making You Talk with the comedian Al Murray.
你们对这个故事的了解比对自己名字的了解还要深。1940年，这或许是近代史上最重要、最浪漫化、也最被神话的一年。欢迎来到《历史的余味》。有时我们会在审视中国或波斯历史时采取宏大而严谨的视角。有时我们会将焦点缩小到某一年，比如我们现在正在做的1940年，并沉浸在这些神话中，或者揭穿它们。所以今天，汤姆的兄弟詹姆斯·霍兰德将加入我们，就好像一个霍兰德还不够似的。詹姆斯对1940年进行了广泛的研究，写过无数关于第二次世界大战的书。他还主持我们出色的姐妹播客，正如汤姆和我喜欢称呼的那样，那是我们的小妹妹播客，与喜剧演员阿尔·默里共同主持的《我们有办法让你开口》（We Have Ways of Making You Talk）。
James, Tom, Hollands, welcome. Well, thank you, Dominic. And it's very exciting to be on and a big fan. So I'm an avid listener. I really enjoyed your 17th century one. Particularly enjoyed the Prime Minister's. That was absolutely fascinating. Prompted me to go and try and find out a little bit more.
詹姆斯、汤姆·霍兰德，欢迎。嗯，谢谢你，多米尼克。能参加节目非常令人兴奋，我是你们的忠实粉丝。我是一个狂热的听众。我真的很喜欢你们关于17世纪的那一期。特别喜欢关于首相的那一期。那绝对令人着迷。促使我去尝试了解更多。
And I also enjoyed the one about entertainment and board games and everything. Great. Well, thank you for listening to The Rest is History. And we'll be back next week with... Can I ask you, what did you make of Dominic's, frankly, histrionic and melodramatic introduction there? Because he was indulging every myth, wasn't he? And knowing you as I do, I know that there's going to be a fair bit of myth busting coming up about the summer of 1940.
我还喜欢关于娱乐和棋盘游戏的那一期。太棒了。嗯，谢谢收听《历史的余味》。我们下周会回来……我可以问你，你觉得多米尼克刚才那段坦率地说有些做作和夸张的开场白怎么样？因为他沉溺于每一个神话，不是吗？而且据我所知，我知道接下来会有不少关于1940年夏天的“破除神话”的内容。
Yeah, but 1940 is still, I mean, the one thing that isn't a myth is just how important it was and how pivotal it was. And, you know, for me, 1940 is just, important it was and how pivotal it was um and you know for me 1940 is just you know it's the daddy year really so can you just give us um just give us a very kind of brief 30 second run through of the greatest hits what are the the absolutely big moments in this this year so so it starts off with the phony war nothing really happening um uh war at sea and that's about it, economic blockade by the Royal Navy of Germany, Battle of Atlanta just starting. And then the British and the French decide to go and stop production of Swedish iron ore reaching Germany.
是的，但1940年仍然，我的意思是，唯一不是神话的一点就是它有多么重要，多么关键。你知道，对我来说，1940年就是，它有多重要，多么关键，嗯，你知道，对我来说，1940年就是，你知道，它真的是“老大哥”年份。所以你能给我们，嗯，给我们做一个非常简短的30秒回顾，讲讲这一年最伟大的成就，这一年里绝对重大的时刻是什么？所以它始于“静坐战争”，什么都没发生，嗯，海上战争，仅此而已，英国皇家海军对德国的经济封锁，大西洋海战刚刚开始。然后英国和法国决定去阻止瑞典铁矿石的生产运往德国。
And at exactly the same time, Germany decides to go and invade Denmark and Holland, which is the first part of April 1940. It goes very badly wrong for the Germans at sea. It goes very, very well for them on land. And then Hitler launches his assault on the West on the 10th of May, 1940, which is the day after Chamberlain has been forced to resign as Prime Minister of Great Britain.
就在同一时间，德国决定入侵丹麦和荷兰，这是1940年4月的第一部分。这对德国人在海上来说非常糟糕。在陆地上却非常、非常顺利。然后希特勒在1940年5月10日发动了对西方的进攻，也就是张伯伦被迫辞去英国首相职务的第二天。
And this is the big strategic earthquake of the Second World War, really, because what happens is German forces sweep into the Low Countries, into Belgium and Holland, and into France, and the French army, which is bigger than the Germans and certainly has more tanks, more artillery pieces, and parity with air power, actually loses and just gets crushed in six weeks.
这确实是第二次世界大战中重大的战略地震，因为发生的事情是德国军队席卷低地国家，进入比利时和荷兰，进入法国，而法国军队，比德国军队规模更大，而且肯定拥有更多的坦克、更多的火炮，在空中力量上也与德国相当，实际上却输了，并在六周内被粉碎。
The British, who have a very, very small army, the British Expeditionary Force, which is part of the Western Allied Forces opposing the Germans, has to kind of fall back in line with the Belgium and French allies either side of them, gets trapped at Dunkirk, has to retreat. And it all looks like the Germans are all conquering master race and unstoppable. And the only thing that sort of the Germans don't complete the capture of France. And then they start thinking about how they're going to get to bring Britain to heel. And so it begins a battle in Britain, which the Luftwaffe loses very badly.
英国人，他们拥有一支非常、非常小的军队，即英国远征军，它是对抗德国人的西方盟军的一部分，不得不与两侧的比利时和法国盟友一起撤退，被困在敦刻尔克，不得不撤离。这一切看起来就像德国人是无所不能的优等民族，势不可挡。唯一的事情是德国人没有完成对法国的占领。然后他们开始考虑如何让英国屈服。于是开始了不列颠战役，德国空军惨败。
And so that's the end of it. And what that means is that Britain's continuing in the fight. It means for Germany, it's got a massive problem on its hand because Britain is still fighting, which means it can't turn east really without fighting on two fronts, which in the last war in 1914, 1918 was one of its biggest problems. And, you know, Germany is caught up in the middle of Europe and is resource poor and all the rest of it. And so it has a massive problem on its hands. So that is why the middle of Europe and is resource poor and all the rest of it and so has a massive problem on its hands so that is why the Battle of Britain in 1940 is so kind of so pivotal really. Wow that's a masterful survey can we take you back right to the beginning so none of nobody can see this happening right no one can see this coming you're talking about the phony war the
所以这就是结局。这意味着英国继续战斗。对德国来说，这意味着它手头有一个巨大的问题，因为英国仍在战斗，这意味着它如果不进行两线作战就无法转向东方，这在1914年到1918年的上一次战争中是它最大的问题之一。而且，你知道，德国被困在欧洲中部，资源匮乏等等。所以它手头有一个巨大的问题。这就是为什么1940年的不列颠战役如此关键。哇，这是一个大师级的综述，我们能带你回到最开始吗？所以没有人能预见到这一切，对吧？没有人能预见到这一点，你谈论的是“静坐战争”，
British and French are basically kind of sitting tight at the beginning of 1940 they don't really have a plan to knock out the Germans. I mean, they've gone into the war to save Poland, which they've manifestly failed to do. Stalin has kind of entered the war at the other extreme. He's taken his bit of Poland. He's eyeing up the Baltic states. Well, they've not promised to save Poland. What they've done is they've promised to defend its sovereignty,
英国和法国在1940年初基本上是按兵不动，他们并没有真正的计划去击垮德国人。我的意思是，他们参战是为了拯救波兰，但他们显然失败了。斯大林在另一个极端进入了战争。他拿走了他那部分的波兰。他正盯着波罗的海国家。好吧，他们并没有承诺拯救波兰。他们承诺的是捍卫其主权，
but that doesn't really mean the same. That doesn't mean we're going to storm in and um through germany and attack you know they've left that quite opaque exactly but that's the point they don't really seem to have a plan about how they're going to win this war that they've that they've now entered right yeah it's really interesting because at the highest level france and britain kind of underestimate the strength of Germany. You know, they look at them and they go, well, they can't possibly do this.
但这并不意味着同样的事情。这并不意味着我们要冲进去，嗯，穿过德国并攻击，你知道，他们把这一点说得很模糊。完全正确，但重点是，他们似乎并没有关于如何赢得这场他们现在已经加入的战争的计划，对吧？是的，这真的很有趣，因为在最高层，法国和英国有点低估了德国的实力。你知道，他们看着他们，然后说，好吧，他们不可能做到这一点。
You know, they just simply don't have the strength. And yet at the same time, you have the commander-in-chief of the French Air Force, the Armie de l'Air, is also completely terrified before the war even begins about the strength of the Luftwaffe and has a completely false idea of how strong it is. There's actually nothing like the strength. And the British as well. The bomber always gets through. There's actually nothing like the strength of the Luftwaffe. And the British as well.
你知道，他们根本没有那种实力。然而与此同时，法国空军（Armie de l'Air）的总司令在战争开始前也对德国空军的实力感到完全恐惧，并且对它有多强大有着完全错误的想法。实际上根本没有那种实力。英国人也是。轰炸机总是能穿透防线。实际上根本没有德国空军那种实力。英国人也是。
The bomber always gets through. There's terror about what the impact might be on civilian populations. Yes, and of course, this is because air power is still so new and it's developing so fast and no one quite knows what it's going to look like when you apply air power in any kind of strength in a new conflict.
轰炸机总是能穿透防线。人们对这对平民人口可能产生的影响感到恐惧。是的，当然，这是因为空中力量还很新，发展得太快，没有人确切知道当你在新的冲突中以任何规模应用空中力量时会是什么样子。
So there's lots of things which are kind of sort of slightly paradoxical because on the one hand, they're quite complacent and on the other hand, they're kind of sort of shitting themselves at the same time. So it's kind of, and this actually goes with what you're saying, Dominic, that there is no kind of quite clear strategy or quite clear plan. And one of the big problems is that Britain and France are confirmed allies. You know, they've signed up to a deal.
所以有很多事情有点自相矛盾，因为一方面，他们相当自满，而另一方面，他们同时又有点吓坏了。所以，这实际上与你所说的一致，多米尼克，即没有一种相当明确的战略或相当明确的计划。而其中一个大问题是英国和法国是确认的盟友。你知道，他们签署了一项协议。
The problem is, particularly with French as as um anyone who's read the dark valley will know um french politics is is just completely um split you know that it's it's one coalition government after the other the problem with military power is if you don't have political power at the top strong political leadership you don't tend not to have strong military leadership and what tends to happen is you have one of a it goes one of what one of two ways either the military revolts and forms a kind of coup which ultimately is what happens with patan um and the fall of france in june 1940 um or it just becomes not very effective which is what happens in may in april and may 1940 and if you don't have that strong political leadership, it's really, really hard for the military to work.
问题是，特别是对于法国人，正如任何读过《黑暗山谷》（The Dark Valley）的人所知道的那样，嗯，法国政治完全是分裂的，你知道，这是一个接一个的联合政府。军事力量的问题在于，如果你在最高层没有强大的政治力量，没有强大的政治领导，你往往就不会有强大的军事领导。而往往发生的情况是，它会走向两个方向之一，要么军队反叛并形成某种政变，这最终就是贝当发生的事情，以及1940年6月法国的沦陷，或者它只是变得不太有效，这就是1940年4月和5月发生的事情。如果你没有那种强大的政治领导，军队就真的、真的很难工作。
And that is really the failing in 1939, where the French army, which is huge, and has a standing army of kind of 1.2 million, and within about 48 hours can be about 3.5 million, something like that. I'm talking slightly off the top of my head. You're talking millions. But the problem is, bro, is that they can't,
而这确实是1939年的失败之处，当时法国军队规模庞大，拥有约120万的常备军，并且在48小时内可以达到约350万，诸如此类。我凭记忆说的。你在谈论数百万。但问题是，兄弟，他们不能，
you know, they're perfectly capable of going into western germany into the rhineland going up the backside of germany while germany's forces are uh diverted in poland and and and it's all over but there is not the political will to let that happen and there is actually what's really interesting when you look at french french soldiers and you look at french accounts of uh memoirs and letters and stuff from 1939, they're really up for it. They're really, really gung-ho, which is in sharp contrast to what happens in Manchurian 1940. So in the British context, is it that sense that really we should be more proactive that leads to the coup against Chamberlain that then brings Churchill to power?
你知道，他们完全有能力进入德国西部，进入莱茵兰，在德国军队被转移到波兰时从德国背后进攻，一切就结束了。但没有政治意愿让这种情况发生。而且实际上，当你观察法国士兵，观察1939年的回忆录和信件等时，你会发现非常有趣的一点是，他们真的很有斗志。他们真的、真的非常积极，这与1940年的情况形成了鲜明对比。那么在英国的背景下，是因为那种我们应该更主动的感觉导致了针对张伯伦的政变，从而使丘吉尔上台吗？
What's going on there? Yeah, so there is... Okay, so at the start of the war, the whole point is that France is going to do the army bit because it's got a massive land power. That's not what we do. We do naval power and we do burgeoning air power. And we have a very, very small standing army
那里发生了什么？是的，所以有……好吧，在战争开始时，重点是法国将负责陆军部分，因为它拥有庞大的陆地力量。那不是我们所做的。我们做的是海军力量和正在萌芽的空中力量。我们有一支非常、非常小的常备军，
and that's really traditional and goes back all the way back to way back when. And, you know, the reason why the Royal Navy is a senior service is because it is the senior service of the three. army and that's that's really traditional goes back all the way back to way back when and you know the reason why the royal navy is a senior service is because it is the senior service of the three and it is absolutely huge it is the world's largest in 1939 and indeed in 1940 what what happens in the reason why chamberlain goes is go is forced out of office is not because of the phony war it's because there's been so much faffing around, neither France or Britain can decide what their strategy should be.
而且这真的很传统，一直追溯到很久以前。而且，你知道，皇家海军之所以是高级军种，是因为它是三个军种中的高级军种。陆军，那真的很传统，一直追溯到很久以前，而且，你知道，皇家海军之所以是高级军种，是因为它是三个军种中的高级军种，而且它绝对庞大，它是1939年乃至1940年世界上规模最大的。张伯伦被迫下台的原因不是因为“静坐战争”，而是因为有太多的拖延，法国或英国都无法决定他们的战略应该是什么。
And the reason the French can't decide is because largely because, you know, it's very simplistic, but in simplistic terms, because of their coalition warfare, where they're going to, you know, their coalition politics, which they can just can't decide anything.
而法国人无法决定的原因很大程度上是因为，你知道，这非常简单，但用简单的话说，是因为他们的联合战争，他们将要，你知道，他们的联合政治，他们就是无法决定任何事情。
So that then has a knock-on effect if you're an ally, because then you can't agree anything. So, you know, it is Churchill, for example, who says, I suggest that we go and you know um mine the leads into um into norway right in the north of norway which is through which um swedish iron ore gets transported down to germany and he suggests that in 19 in september 1939 it's quite a good idea in september 1939 but it's a really bad idea by april 1940 because you know everything's changed it's just they've just been faffing around too long no one no one can make a mind their mind up and so everyone gets frustrated about that and
所以这会对盟友产生连锁反应，因为那样你就无法达成任何共识。所以，你知道，例如是丘吉尔说，我建议我们去，你知道，嗯，在挪威的航道上布雷，就在挪威北部，瑞典铁矿石通过那里运往德国，他在1939年9月提出了这个建议。在1939年9月这是一个相当好的主意，但到1940年4月就是一个非常糟糕的主意，因为你知道一切都变了。他们只是拖延得太久了，没有人能下定决心，所以每个人都对此感到沮丧，并且
then what happens is that Germany then goes into invades um Denmark and Norway at precisely the same time that the the mining operation is just about to about to begin and on on the ground which is what catches the news headlines and where you get the footage you know the film footage and all the rest of it rather than out at sea which is out at sea where no one can see. You know, the Germans are all conquering. And so we've been faffing around, nothing's happened. There's a sense that we've kind of missed an opportunity to give the Germans a bloody nose when we had the opportunity
然后发生的事情是，德国在布雷行动即将开始的同时入侵了丹麦和挪威，而在地面上，这正是占据新闻头条的地方，也是你获得电影片段和所有其他东西的地方，而不是在海上，在海上没有人能看到。你知道，德国人是无所不能的。所以我们一直在拖延，什么都没发生。有一种感觉，我们错过了一个在1939年秋天有机会给德国人一点教训的机会。
in the autumn of 1939. We've left it too late. We've missed the bus. And consequently, through the ineptitude of our political leadership, we've now been defeated on the ground in Norway. And the Germans have got a big foothold. And they kind of sort of ignore the fact that the Luftwaffe, sorry, the Kriegsmarine, the German Navy,
我们做得太晚了。我们错过了机会。因此，由于我们政治领导层的无能，我们现在在挪威的地面上被击败了。德国人获得了一个巨大的立足点。他们有点忽略了德国空军，抱歉，德国海军，
has had a massive bloody nose at the hands of the Royal Navy, particularly in the Norway battle. But that is what forces Chamberlain to go out. It's also that classic example of political leadership being as much about image as it is about substance isn't it though james i mean chamberlain doesn't you see this in people's diaries in the spring of 1940 chamberlain doesn't exude the air of a war leader so he's sort of reading us and his kind of beacon us and his i mean he's he he says his umbrella i've always been a man of peace. He says that in the Declaration of War.
在挪威战役中在皇家海军手中遭受了巨大的打击。但这就是迫使张伯伦下台的原因。这也是政治领导力既关乎形象又关乎实质的经典例子，不是吗，詹姆斯？我的意思是，张伯伦并没有，你在1940年春天的日记中可以看到这一点，张伯伦并没有散发出战争领导人的气息，所以他有点在读我们，他的那种灯塔，我的意思是，他，他说他的雨伞，我一直是一个和平主义者。他在宣战时说了这一点。
I'm a man of peace. You know, this is, when we declare war in 1939, straight after saying, you know, this country is now at war with Germany. I have to say, this country is now at war. And it just sounds awful, doesn't it? But he then says, you can imagine what a bitter blow it is to me. And this sort of slight element of self-pity.
我是一个和平主义者。你知道，这是，当我们1939年宣战时，紧接着说，你知道，这个国家现在正与德国处于战争状态。我不得不说，这个国家现在正处于战争状态。这听起来很糟糕，不是吗？但他随后说，你可以想象这对我是多么沉重的打击。这种轻微的自怜成分。
I mean, he doesn't have the sort of boisterous, swashbuckling sort of braggadocio that Churchill brings. And that's one reason why Churchill also is a man of war. Churchill has been an omdurman. He's been in the First World War. He's a man who famously glories in war. And so I think the fall of Chamberlain is, to me, it's a classic example of how in politics, appearance matters, and style matters as much
我的意思是，他没有丘吉尔带来的那种喧闹、挥舞剑的虚张声势。这就是为什么丘吉尔也是一个战争男人的原因之一。丘吉尔曾在恩图曼。他曾在第一次世界大战中。他是一个以在战争中荣耀而闻名的人。所以我认为张伯伦的倒台，对我来说，是一个经典的例子，说明在政治中，外表很重要，风格和实质一样重要。
as substance. Yeah, absolutely. And by 1939, and by 1940, you know, you are in a media age, you know, you absolutely are, you know, your voice is heard over the radio and all the rest of it, you know, there is news footage on, you know, the precede all the major feature films, which is your main source of entertainment at that time, going to the cinema. So, you know, politicians are much more visual than they'd ever been before. I mean... But it's about more than image, isn't it?
是的，绝对是。到1939年，到1940年，你知道，你处于一个媒体时代，你知道，你绝对是，你知道，你的声音通过广播被听到，诸如此类，你知道，有新闻片段在，你知道，在所有主要故事片之前播放，这是当时你主要的娱乐来源，去电影院。所以，你知道，政治家比以往任何时候都更具视觉感。我的意思是……但这不仅仅是关于形象，不是吗？
Yeah, he just wasn't very good. It's about the fact that Churchill actually would be very, very proactive. And so there's a famous book by John Lukacs, the historian, Five Days in London, where he basically says that, you says that this is the throttle point of 20th century history. This is the moment where the Germans could have won the war. The Allies could have lost it. Do you go along with that? Yes, I absolutely do.
是的，他只是不太好。这是关于丘吉尔实际上会非常、非常主动的事实。所以有一本著名的书，由历史学家约翰·卢卡奇（John Lukacs）所著，《伦敦的五天》（Five Days in London），他基本上说，他说这是20世纪历史的瓶颈点。这是德国人本可以赢得战争的时刻。盟军本可以输掉它。你同意这一点吗？是的，我绝对同意。
What's going on in Whitehall and Westminster at this point? Because the question over who will succeed Chamberlain, will it be Halifax? Will it be Churchill? Will it be someone else? Is this of that seismic significance, as Lukács says? Yes, well, Lukács is talking about the five days in May, at the end of May.
此时白厅和威斯敏斯特发生了什么？因为关于谁将接替张伯伦的问题，是哈利法克斯吗？是丘吉尔吗？还是其他人？这有卢卡奇所说的那种地震般的意义吗？是的，好吧，卢卡奇谈论的是5月的五天，在5月底。
What we're talking about is the ousting of Chamberlain and inserting of Churchill as prime minister, which happens on the 9th, 10th of May, which coincidentally is the same day that the Germans launched Case Yellow, which is the invasion of the West. And don't forget that the favourite to take over from Chamberlain is another kind of peacetime politician, is Lord Halifax, who has been the foreign secretary and continues as foreign secretary. He doesn't want the job,
我们谈论的是罢免张伯伦并任命丘吉尔为首相，这发生在5月9日、10日，巧合的是，这正是德国发动“黄色方案”（Case Yellow）的那一天，也就是对西方的入侵。别忘了，接替张伯伦的热门人选是另一位和平时期的政治家，哈利法克斯勋爵，他曾担任外交大臣，并继续担任外交大臣。他不想要这份工作，
but that is what everyone, you know, had he said, yeah, all right, I'll do it, he would have been prime minister and not Churchill. Fast forward to, you know, so when Halifax doesn't do it, there is no one else who could do that job other than Churchill. That's why he gets it.
但那是每个人，你知道，如果他说，是的，好吧，我会做，他就会是首相而不是丘吉尔。快进到，你知道，所以当哈利法克斯没有这样做时，除了丘吉尔之外，没有人能做那份工作。这就是他得到它的原因。
You know, so he becomes prime minister, you know, because an existing voted-in-for Prime Minister has been ousted. You know, he's not the elected Prime Minister. But also because Labour will back him, James. He has support from Labour. Yes, but I think Labour would have supported Halifax
你知道，所以他成为首相，你知道，因为一位现任的、投票选出的首相被罢免了。你知道，他不是民选首相。但也是因为工党会支持他，詹姆斯。他得到了工党的支持。是的，但我认为工党也会支持哈利法克斯
as well. You know, Halifax has his reputation as being the most honest, straightest, level-headed politician in the land you know he's seen as safe as you know he's got this uh you know he's been a former viceroy of india he's got a long career in politics but you know he's he would have been catastrophically bad as prime minister so it's it's great relief that that he wouldn't even have been in the commons would he he wouldn't even be in the commons no it'd be disaster. And he felt ill about the whole thing.
的。你知道，哈利法克斯以作为土地上最诚实、最正直、最冷静的政治家而闻名，你知道，他被视为安全，你知道，他曾是印度总督，他在政治上有很长的职业生涯，但你知道，他作为首相会是灾难性的糟糕，所以他甚至不会在下议院，不是吗？他甚至不会在下议院，不，那将是灾难。而且他一想到整件事就感到恶心。
And, you know, anyone who's sort of making themselves feel ill just at the thought of it, you know, clearly isn't the right person for the job. So, you know, thank goodness that he kind of, you know, he realised his own shortcomings and didn't take it on. You know, Churchill was absolutely the man. But Churchill was coming as very much sort of damaged goods at that point. I mean, he's not, you know, he's not the Churchill in...
而且，你知道，任何仅仅因为想到它就让自己感到恶心的人，你知道，显然不是这份工作的合适人选。所以，你知道，谢天谢地，他有点，你知道，他意识到了自己的缺点，没有承担起来。你知道，丘吉尔绝对是那个人。但丘吉尔当时被视为非常受损的商品。我的意思是，他不是，你知道，他不是那个在……
The Churchill of 10th of May 1940 is not the Churchill of even late June 1940. You know, he's quite a different... You know, politically, he's not that empowered at that point. You know, and there's still some massive guns within the War Cabinet. So you have the wider Cabinet, which is about 30 people. Then you have the War Cabinet, which is five.
1940年5月10日的丘吉尔不是1940年6月下旬的丘吉尔。你知道，他是一个完全不同的人……你知道，在政治上，他当时并没有那么大的权力。你知道，战时内阁中仍然有一些巨大的枪支。所以你有更广泛的内阁，大约有30人。然后你有战时内阁，有五个人。
So it's him, Chamberlain, the former Prime Minister, is still in the War Cabinet, Halifax. And then it's it's it's him chamberlain the former prime minister is still in the war cabinet halifax um and then it's arthur greenwood and clement atley the two labor boys but they're so new to it that their their influence at this stage is very very small so then you move on to the five days in may which is the 27th of may up to the kind of you know second of first of june and that that is the kind of pivotal moment and actually when that's the 26th of may isn't it sunday the 26th which is national day of prayer which the king calls for um and that that is the kind of pivotal moment and actually when that's the 26th of May isn't it Sunday the 26th which is a national day of prayer which the king calls for um and that is where it all looks incredibly bleak because what has happened is is the Germans have okay okay
所以是他，前首相张伯伦，仍然在战时内阁，哈利法克斯。然后是，是他，前首相张伯伦，仍然在战时内阁，哈利法克斯，嗯，然后是阿瑟·格林伍德和克莱门特·艾德礼，那两个工党小伙子，但他们对它太陌生了，以至于他们在这个阶段的影响力非常、非常小。所以你进入了5月的五天，也就是5月27日到，你知道，6月1日或2日，那是一个关键时刻，实际上，那是5月26日，不是吗？星期天，26日，这是国王呼吁的全国祈祷日，嗯，那是一个关键时刻，实际上，那是5月26日，不是吗？星期天，26日，这是国王呼吁的全国祈祷日，嗯，那就是一切看起来极其暗淡的地方，因为发生了什么，德国人已经，好吧，好吧，
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on okay so we've got we've got Churchill in place and we've done the politics in in in Westminster let's go back to then the onset of the war we've got a question from Tim B was there anything the British could have done to stop the onset of the war. We've got a question from Tim B. Was there anything the British could have done to stop the invasion of France? Or given the lack of French coordination and German aggression, was it inevitable? So is there anything that could have been done to spike the Blitzkrieg?
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，好吧，所以我们有丘吉尔到位了，我们已经在威斯敏斯特完成了政治。让我们回到战争的开始，我们有一个来自蒂姆·B的问题，英国有什么办法可以阻止战争的开始吗？我们有一个来自蒂姆·B的问题。英国有什么办法可以阻止对法国的入侵吗？或者考虑到法国缺乏协调和德国的侵略，这是不可避免的吗？所以有什么办法可以阻止闪电战吗？
I don't think there's anything that the British could have done other than what they were doing because their army is so small. It's just, you know, it doesn't, you know, if you've got a small army, you don't have any clout in the decision-making process on land operations.
我不认为英国除了他们正在做的事情之外还能做些什么，因为他们的军队太小了。这只是，你知道，它没有，你知道，如果你有一支小军队，你在陆地行动的决策过程中就没有影响力。
And it was agreed as part of the alliance that the French would take the lead. So the British would have a power of veto, but they would be subordinate to the French commanders. So from a land point of view, no. You're also operating aircraft out of France. And so you're also playing a subordinate role to the Army of the Air. So you can't do anything about that. The only place where you can actually have... Britain has a decisive and leading role is at sea, and it's doing all that it can do.
而且作为联盟的一部分，双方同意法国将处于领先地位。所以英国会有否决权，但他们会从属于法国指挥官。所以从陆地的角度来看，没有。你也在法国操作飞机。所以你也扮演着从属于空军的角色。所以你对此无能为力。英国唯一能拥有……英国拥有决定性和领导作用的地方是在海上，而且它正在尽其所能。
It's imposed a blockade on Germany right from the word go, and that's incredibly effective, really. There's not much else you can do, really, so no. I don't think there's anything else that Britain could have done. But I think the French could have stopped it in 1939. Let's's rephrase that is there any when the blitzkrieg begins is there anything the french could have done to stop it or was it always going to work they could have done something in september 1939 if they'd gone into west germany western germany in 1939 in strength coordinated with a coordinated attack it would have brought germany to its knees
它从一开始就对德国实施了封锁，这确实非常有效。真的没有其他你能做的了，所以没有。我不认为英国还能做些什么。但我认为法国本可以在1939年阻止它。让我们换个说法，当闪电战开始时，法国有什么办法可以阻止它，还是它注定会成功？如果他们在1939年9月以强大的力量进入德国西部，并协调一致地进行攻击，他们本可以使德国屈服。
i'm that i have absolutely no doubt but once the blish king is launched it's it's it's it's over for france yeah it's too late well not not on paper certainly um the the problem with the french is uh you know that and when when uh paul reyna rings up churchill and says you know we have lost we've lost the battle um days in, four days in. That is because the River Meuse has been crossed. Now, the way the French have organised themselves is they've assumed that the Second World War is going to be fought very much like the First World. It's going to be long and attritional and largely static. In actual fact, they've got kind of two parts of that right, as it turns out. It's just the static bit that they've got wrong. And unfortunately, that's rather bad news. So the French more you know they have a parity really in terms of troops
我对此绝对没有怀疑，但一旦闪电战发动，法国就完了。是的，太晚了。好吧，在纸面上当然不是，嗯，法国人的问题是，嗯，你知道，当保罗·雷诺打电话给丘吉尔说，你知道，我们输了，我们输掉了战斗，四天后。这是因为默兹河被跨越了。现在，法国人组织自己的方式是，他们假设第二次世界大战将非常像第一次世界大战。它将是漫长的、消耗性的，并且在很大程度上是静态的。实际上，事实证明，他们对其中的两个部分是正确的。只是他们搞错了静态的部分。不幸的是，这相当糟糕。所以法国人，你知道，他们在部队方面确实有相当的实力，
um they have double the number of artillery pieces they have a parity pretty much in terms of um of aircraft alone but that's before you add the ref and the and the dutch air force and belgian air force and all the rest of it um they've also got considerably more tanks and better tanks with higher guns thicker armor and all that kind of stuff so on paper there should be no no problem whatsoever and they're being defensive you know they're on the defense and defending is considerably easier than it is attacking you know you need something like you know the rule of thumb military rule of thumb throughout history is a three to one advantage for your attacking force and this is why germany over the years you know we were talking about it with catcher hire the other day you know when you're doing when they're attacking I don't know Denmark in 1864 or Austria in 1866 or whatever it is or
嗯，他们拥有的火炮数量是德国的两倍，他们仅在飞机方面就基本相当，但这还没算上英国皇家空军、荷兰空军和比利时空军等等，嗯，他们还拥有相当多的坦克，而且是更好的坦克，拥有更高的火炮、更厚的装甲等等，所以在纸面上应该完全没有问题，而且他们处于防御状态，你知道，他们处于防御状态，防御比进攻容易得多，你知道，你需要某种，你知道，历史上的军事经验法则是进攻部队拥有三比一的优势，这就是为什么德国多年来，你知道，我们前几天和卡彻·海尔谈论过它，你知道，当你在做，当他们在进攻时，我不知道，1864年的丹麦或1866年的奥地利，或者无论是什么，或者
France in 1870 you know what they do is they have the schwerpunkt which is they concentrate on this mass of forces at the main point and quickly do an encirclement a kettle schlacht and annihilate your enemy really quickly but it all has to be done incredibly quickly with a huge amount of speed. That's what they're trying to do in 1914. It just doesn't work. And it's exactly what they're trying to do in 1940. And they do it substantially more successfully. But the French don't have an answer for this because the new development, the tactics the Germans are using are the same that they've always been. It's exactly the same model. This goes all the way back beyond Frederick the Great to the greater frederick the elector you know etc etc i mean this is how the germans and before them the prussians have always fought their battles um but the difference is really twofold
1870年的法国，你知道他们做的是他们拥有“重心”（Schwerpunkt），也就是他们集中在这个主要点的力量，并迅速进行包围，进行“歼灭战”（Kessel-schlacht），并非常迅速地消灭你的敌人，但这必须以极快的速度完成。这就是他们在1914年试图做的事情。它只是不起作用。而这正是他们在1940年试图做的事情。而且他们做得成功得多。但法国人对此没有答案，因为新的发展，德国人使用的战术和他们一直以来的一样。这完全是同一个模型。这一直追溯到腓特烈大帝之前，追溯到大选侯腓特烈，你知道等等等等，我的意思是这就是德国人，以及在他们之前的普鲁士人一直进行战斗的方式，但区别确实是双重的，
first of all they've now got the luftwaffe operating um operating with close air support what we would call a tactical air force, there to support ground operations primarily. And it's evolved organically because Germany is a continental land power. The second thing is radio technology, which the Germans are masters of. And it's very, very interesting that while they are kind of languishing a long, long way down in kind of mechanisation, they are one of the least automotive modern societies in the world in 1939. They have more radios per person than any other country in the entire world including the united states one of the reasons for this is because of the nazis and they're developing a propaganda and all the rest of it
首先，他们现在有了德国空军在运作，在近距离空中支援下运作，我们称之为战术空军，主要在那里支持地面行动。而且它是自然演变的，因为德国是一个大陆陆地强国。第二件事是无线电技术，德国人是这方面的大师。而且非常、非常有趣的是，虽然他们在机械化方面滞后了很远，但他们在1939年是世界上汽车化程度最低的现代社会之一。他们每人拥有的收音机比世界上任何其他国家都多，包括美国。造成这种情况的原因之一是因为纳粹，他们正在发展宣传等等，
and this realization that if you can get get your voice and your message over to a lot of people that's incredibly powerful so what they then do is they develop very very cheap radios and if you kind of think back of radio sets in 1939 and the 1930s, they're kind of lovely, great, ornate kind of, you know, chestnut wooden things that you sort of put on your sideboard. Well, what the Germans develop is the Deutsche Keinenfanger, which is the German little radio, which is nine inches by four inches by four inches.
以及这种认识，即如果你能把你的声音和信息传达给很多人，那是极其强大的。所以他们随后开发了非常、非常便宜的收音机，如果你回想一下1939年和1930年代的收音机，它们是那种可爱的、巨大的、华丽的、你知道，栗色木制的东西，你把它放在餐具柜上。好吧，德国人开发的是“德国小收音机”（Deutsche Keinenfanger），也就是德国小收音机，它是9英寸乘4英寸乘4英寸。
And this is, you know, this is as revolutionary as the introduction of the iPod, because it's tiny and it's cheap, and it means that everyone can have one. And what the army realizes, hang on a minute, if you can make radios really small, then we can put them in our Panzers. We can put them in our groovy little kind of BMWs with sidecars. We can put them with our artillery and with our motorized infantry. And suddenly, we can create a thing called a Panzer division. And a panzer division is not stuff full of of tanks it's got tanks yes but it's also got
而且这是，你知道，这和iPod的推出一样具有革命性，因为它很小而且很便宜，这意味着每个人都可以拥有一个。而军队意识到，等一下，如果你能把收音机做得非常小，那么我们就可以把它们放在我们的装甲车里。我们可以把它们放在我们那种很酷的带边车的宝马里。我们可以把它们放在我们的火炮和摩托化步兵里。突然之间，我们可以创造一个叫做装甲师的东西。而一个装甲师并不是装满了坦克，它有坦克，是的，但它也有
motorized infantry motorized artillery motorized reconnaissance um it's got all the components you need for a little battle group and they can all communicate with each other which is one of the great problems of the first world war in the Western Front. So they can all communicate to each other, which the French haven't developed. So, you know, the commander-in-chief, Moïse Gamelin, the commander-in-chief of French forces at the Château de Marseille, just on the edge of Paris, you know, that doesn't have a radio system in it at all, which means the French are then completely dependent
摩托化步兵、摩托化炮兵、摩托化侦察，它拥有你需要的所有小战斗群的组件，而且它们都可以互相交流，这是第一次世界大战西线战场上的大问题之一。所以它们都可以互相交流，这是法国人没有开发的。所以，你知道，总司令，莫里斯·甘末林，法国军队的总司令，在巴黎边缘的马赛城堡，你知道，那里根本没有无线电系统，这意味着法国人完全依赖
on field, you know normal telephone lines or dispatch riders and of course what happens is the stook has come over and you know bombers and stuff and shoot up the telephone lines and cut the lines um so they're then dependent on dispatch riders and but by and because they're so top heavy they've got army groups overall army command then army groups then armies then corps then divisions and brigades and you know battalions and so on and so it goes down every single time you're trying to get an order and you've got to send a little gun and motorbike and you're then fighting refugees and he then gets shot or whatever or doesn't make it back and then you've got to send another one out the whole thing they're just
野战，你知道正常的电话线或通讯骑兵，当然发生的事情是斯图卡俯冲轰炸机飞过来，你知道轰炸机之类的东西，把电话线打断了，切断了线路，所以他们随后依赖通讯骑兵，但因为他们太头重脚轻了，他们有集团军总指挥部，然后是集团军，然后是军，然后是师和旅，你知道营等等，所以每次你试图得到一个命令时，你都得派一个小伙子骑摩托车，然后你还要和难民战斗，他然后被射杀或者无论怎样，或者没能回来，然后你得再派一个出去，整件事他们只是
like rabbits in headlights they just get completely ground to a halt so you can't bring that massive force together and what the germ Germans are then able to do is beat them in penny packets. And that is what happens. Tom, when we invited your brother on, I knew we would have long discussions about tanks. And that is precisely what just happened. I'm sorry about that.
像车灯前的兔子，他们完全陷入了停滞，所以你无法把那支庞大的部队聚集在一起，而德国人随后能够以零敲碎打的方式击败他们。这就是发生的事情。汤姆，当我们邀请你兄弟来的时候，我就知道我们会就坦克进行长时间的讨论。而这正是刚刚发生的事情。对此我很抱歉。
I'm glad not to disappoint. Just before we go to a break, I want to ask you a to stress's question so the germans are basically they've wiped the floor with a french they're charging forward you know all looks good for the germans and then they stop they pause and this is a sort of crucial moment in this whole story and some people would argue it's sort of turning point in the war they stop before dunkirk they don't base they don't carry on and wipe out the British. They give the British time to escape. Now, addicted to stress, his question is, is that because Hitler wants to deal with the British and
我很高兴没有让人失望。在休息之前，我想问你一个关于压力的问题，所以德国人基本上把法国人打得落花流水，他们正在向前冲锋，你知道，一切对德国人来说看起来都很好，然后他们停了下来，他们暂停了，这是整个故事中的一个关键时刻，有些人会争辩说这是战争的转折点，他们在敦刻尔克之前停了下来，他们基本上没有继续消灭英国人。他们给了英国人逃跑的时间。现在，沉迷于压力，他的问题是，这是因为希特勒想处理英国和
the British Empire, or is it because the German lines are too stretched or whatever, and they have to stop for kind of logistical reasons? It's ostensibly for the latter reason, but it's really because Hitler is trying to impose his authority over the army command um and and he's trying to show who's boss um and as a result of that he arguably loses the war it's really really fascinating i mean the point is is that what one has to understand is these mobile armored divisions out of the 135 divisions that are used and the division is about 15 000 men that is the kind of unit by which we judge sizes of armies in the second world war um of the 135 divisions that the germans use in in the in the attack in the west um only 16 are motorized so the rest are using their own two
大英帝国，还是因为德国的战线拉得太长了等等，他们必须因为后勤原因停下来？表面上是后勤原因，但实际上是因为希特勒试图在军队指挥部强加他的权威，嗯，他试图展示谁是老板，结果他可以说输掉了战争。这真的、真的非常迷人，我的意思是，重点是，一个人必须理解的是，这些移动装甲师，在使用的135个师中，一个师大约有15000人，这是我们在第二次世界大战中判断军队规模的单位，嗯，在德国人在西方进攻中使用的135个师中，只有16个是摩托化的，其余的都在用他们自己的两条
feet or they're using horse and cart horses on the thousands of loads of horses yep yep 1.5 million horses in in the first world war two and a half million in the second. And so it is these 16 divisions which are motorised, which are mechanised, which are doing all the hard yards. They are very much the kind of the point of the spear. The horses and the guys on their feet are the kind of shaft of the spear. And they are doing all the hard yards. But this is completely new. You know, they haven't done this before.
腿，或者他们在使用马车，马，成千上万的马。是的，是的，第一次世界大战中有150万匹马，第二次世界大战中有250万匹。所以正是这16个摩托化的、机械化的师在做所有的苦差事。他们非常像是矛尖。马和步行的人是矛杆。他们正在做所有的苦差事。但这完全是新的。你知道，他们以前没做过这个。
So those old, crustier kind of, you know, the von Kleist,ist the von rundstedt these older prussian aristocratic kind of generals this is all new and they get nervous that the the spearhead is overreaching itself so von kleist who is commander of one of the great panzer groups um which is doing this the southern sweep through army group um a um sweeping around from the south southern heart of it through the Ardennes and all the rest of it, getting across the River Meuse. He starts to get nervous that the panzer divisions are overextending
所以那些老派的、更顽固的，你知道，冯·克莱斯特，冯·伦德施泰特，这些老普鲁士贵族将军，这一切都是新的，他们开始担心矛尖正在过度扩张，
and getting too far ahead of the infantry divisions, which are sort of plodding on behind. So he imposes a halt order. General Halder, who is the chief of staff of the army, realises that this is catastrophic just at the moment they've got of closing in a complete encirclement around the French and British army in northern France.
并且跑得太远，超过了在后面缓慢行进的步兵师。所以他下达了停止命令。陆军参谋长哈尔德将军意识到，就在他们即将对法国和英国军队在法国北部的包围圈进行收网的关键时刻，这是灾难性的。
This is not the time to be cautious. This is the time to absolutely go for it. And so he rescinds the order. The following day, the 24th of May, Hitler turns up to see von Rundstedt, who is the overall commander of Army Group A, and says, what are all your Panzer divisions doing? And he goes, well, I don't know,
现在不是谨慎行事的时候，现在是必须全力以赴的时候。于是他撤销了命令。第二天，也就是5月24日，希特勒去见了A集团军群总司令冯·龙德施泰特，问道：“你们所有的装甲师都在干什么？”他回答说：“嗯，我不知道，”
because Halder's transferred them all over to Army Group B, which is the ones coming through the top, through Belgium and Holland. So they're no longer part of my command. And Hitler absolutely goes ballistic at this. You know, how dare Halder kind of, you know, make this decision, von Brauchert, who's the commander-in-chief of the army,
“因为哈尔德把他们全都调到了B集团军群，也就是从上面，通过比利时和荷兰进攻的那支部队。所以他们不再归我指挥了。”希特勒对此勃然大怒。你知道，哈尔德怎么敢做出这种决定，还有陆军总司令冯·布劳希奇，
how dare they make this decision without consulting me first? There's something as major as transferring the panzer elites over to a different army group you know I'm just completely I I I countermand that order completely you're now back in charge and it's up to you when you when you release the panzers and let them go on the march again um and and so this is humiliates von Browkitch humiliates Halder they have absolutely not a leg to stand on. And consequently, von Rundstedt doesn't then release them again until 1.30pm on the afternoon of the 26th of May,
他们怎么敢在不先咨询我的情况下做出这种决定？像把装甲精英调到另一个集团军群这样重大的事情，我完全……我完全撤销那道命令，你现在重新掌权，由你决定何时释放装甲部队，让他们再次出发。这羞辱了冯·布劳希奇，羞辱了哈尔德，他们完全站不住脚。因此，直到5月26日下午1点30分，冯·龙德施泰特才再次释放了他们，
by which time those orders have been fed, it's about eight o'clock at night. And so actually the panzers don't get moving until the 27th of May, by which time it's too late. And so then the British are able to get away. But Dominic, just before we go to the break, one last question from Gregory gregory doll on dunk on dunkirk um he asked what would have happened if they'd only got a hundred thousand or fewer of dunkirk so i guess really
到那时命令传达下去，已经是晚上八点左右了。所以实际上装甲部队直到5月27日才开始行动，那时已经太晚了。于是英国人得以逃脱。但是多米尼克，在休息之前，我想问格雷戈里·多尔关于敦刻尔克的一个最后问题，他问如果他们只救出了十万人或更少，会发生什么？所以我猜真正的问题是
the question is how important is it the british army gets away from dunkirk well i think the the events of monday the 27th of may which for me is is the is the closest that britain ever comes to losing the war, those events might not have played out in the same way had the BEF looked like it was going to be completely destroyed. I think that's the interesting thing. Okay, well, I can hear the air raid sirens, so I think we should take a break while we wait for the all clear, and we'll be back after the break. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
英国军队从敦刻尔克撤离有多重要？嗯，我认为5月27日星期一发生的事件，对我来说是英国最接近输掉战争的时刻，如果英国远征军看起来要被彻底歼灭，这些事件可能就不会以同样的方式发展了。我认为这才是最有趣的地方。好了，我能听到空袭警报了，所以我想我们应该在等待解除警报的同时休息一下，休息后我们会回来。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History with Tom Holland, me Dominic Sandbrook and our special guest James Holland. Now next week we'll be talking about 1066 and we'll also be talking about our very favourite eunuchs. Everybody's got a favourite eunuch haven't they? So get your questions in on Twitter and we'll try to go through as many of them as possible.
这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕后，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和优先购买现场票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到由汤姆·霍兰、我多米尼克·桑德布鲁克以及我们的特邀嘉宾詹姆斯·霍兰主持的《其余皆历史》。下周我们将讨论1066年，还会讨论我们最喜欢的太监。每个人都有一个最喜欢的太监，对吧？所以请在推特上提出你们的问题，我们会尽量回答尽可能多的问题。
And we are also going to do an episode live on the internet next Wednesday, April the 21st. And the subject is assassinations. So Abraham Lincoln, John F. Kennedy, Julius Caesar. We've got them all. Failed assassinations as well. Failed assassinations as well. Failed assassinations, exactly. Well, Hilary Mantel wrote a book about her short story
我们还将在下周三，4月21日，在互联网上进行一场直播。主题是暗杀。所以亚伯拉罕·林肯、约翰·F·肯尼迪、尤利乌斯·凯撒。我们都有。还有失败的暗杀。还有失败的暗杀。失败的暗杀，没错。嗯，希拉里·曼特尔写过一本关于她短篇小说的书，
about the assassination of Margaret Thatcher, didn't she? So maybe assassinations that never happened at all. Anyway, it's free for anybody to join, and we'll send out a link on Twitter next week. Tom, here we are with your brother, and you have a question for him from Rolf Merchant, I believe. Well, so before the break, we were in the process of getting the British from the beaches of Dunkirk. France is in the process of being defeated.
关于暗杀玛格丽特·撒切尔的，不是吗？所以也许是那些从未发生的暗杀。总之，任何人都可以免费参加，我们下周会在推特上发布链接。汤姆，我们现在和你哥哥在一起，我相信罗尔夫·默钱特有一个问题要问他。嗯，在休息之前，我们正在把英国人从敦刻尔克的沙滩上撤离。法国正在被击败。
It's looking bad. All kinds of political shenanigans going on in Whitehall and Westminster. And I think that this is the perfect time to ask Rolf Merchant's question. He says, what might a negotiated settlement with Germany have looked like had Britain decided against fighting on? Presumably so unpalatable for the British that it was never a realistic option. So I guess two questions there. Were there serious attempts to put out peace feelers? And had those peace feelers been, you know, gone a bit further? What might a negotiated settlement have looked like for britain in in the end of may 1940 well i do think it would i mean i'm i'm not i
情况看起来很糟糕。白厅和威斯敏斯特发生了各种政治勾当。我认为这是问罗尔夫·默钱特问题的最佳时机。他说，如果英国决定不再继续战斗，与德国的谈判协议会是什么样子？大概对英国人来说太令人难以接受了，所以从来都不是一个现实的选择。所以我猜有两个问题。是否有过认真的尝试去试探和平？如果这些和平试探稍微深入一点，1940年5月底英国的谈判协议会是什么样子？嗯，我确实认为它会……我的意思是，我不是……我
know you've done a whole episode on what ifs but i'm not a massive fan of what ifs at all but um um i think you can say fairly safely that it would have been very very bad news um i think it would have been so the the key moment as far as i can make out is between sunday the 26th of may 1940 and tuesday the 28th with the really crux of it probably being somewhere in the afternoon of the monday the 27th of may so operation dynamo which is the operation to evacuate the BEF, is launched on the afternoon, about 5.30 in the afternoon on that Sunday, which the King has already called as a national day of prayer. So bad is the situation. And so shocked and stunned are the British ruling class, but also the wider public as well by what has happened on the and over that weekend um lord halifax who um as we were talking about was the most likely candidate to replace chamberlain before refusing to take on the job and so it falls to churchill instead has been talking to um giuseppe bastanini who is the italian ambassador
知道你们做过一整集关于“如果”的节目，但我一点也不喜欢“如果”。但是……我认为可以相当肯定地说，那将是非常非常糟糕的消息。我认为关键时刻，据我所知，是在1940年5月26日星期日到5月28日星期二之间，最关键的时刻可能是在5月27日星期一的下午。所以“发电机行动”，也就是撤离英国远征军的行动，是在那个星期天的下午，大约5点30分发起的，国王已经将其定为全国祈祷日。情况就是这么糟糕。英国统治阶级，以及更广泛的公众，对那个周末发生的事情感到如此震惊和惊愕，以至于……哈利法克斯勋爵，正如我们所谈到的，他是张伯伦最可能的继任者，但在拒绝接手这份工作后，它落到了丘吉尔身上，他一直在与意大利大使朱塞佩·巴斯塔尼尼交谈，
about the possibility of opening peace feelers. Now, as it happens, there is a spat within the war cabinet. So there is the wider cabinet, which is made up of about 30 or so people, cabinet ministers. And then there is the war cabinet, which is just five strong. And there is Churchill, who's prime minister,
关于开启和平试探的可能性。现在，碰巧的是，战时内阁内部发生了争执。所以有更广泛的内阁，由大约30人左右的内阁大臣组成。然后是战时内阁，只有五个人。有丘吉尔，他是首相，
Lord Halifax, who's foreign secretary. Then there is Neville Chamberlain, the ousted prime minister, but a giant of the political stage in Britain at the time. And then there is Clement Attlee and Arthur Greenwood, who are two Labour guys, who have just come in and are very much the new boys. So yes, their views count, but they don't count half as much as Halifax and Chamberlain's and, of course, Churchill's. And a dispute breaks out on that Monday, the 27th, about what they should do, you know, should the BEF not be evacuated.
哈利法克斯勋爵，他是外交大臣。然后是内维尔·张伯伦，被赶下台的首相，但当时是英国政坛的巨人。然后是克莱门特·艾德礼和阿瑟·格林伍德，他们是两个工党成员，刚刚加入，是非常新的成员。所以是的，他们的观点很重要，但没有哈利法克斯和张伯伦，当然还有丘吉尔的观点那么重要。在那周一，即27日，爆发了一场争论，关于他们应该做什么，你知道，如果英国远征军不能撤离的话。
And the estimates, when Operation Dynamo is launched on that Sunday evening, the estimates are 40,000, if we're lucky. So what did they get out? 338,000. They got out all of them right so they got out every single man who was was able to get on board a ship was was a boarder ship i mean loads of wounded were left behind there was another whole kind of you know best part of 200 000 that were later picked up in in um uh further south um and in in normandy later on but but but for dunkirk it's 338 000
当“发电机行动”在那个周日晚上启动时，估计如果运气好的话能救出4万人。那么他们救出了多少？338,000人。他们救出了所有人，对吧？所以他们救出了每一个能够登上船的人。我的意思是，大量的伤员被留下了，还有另外近20万人在后来在南部……在诺曼底被接走，但就敦刻尔克而言，是338,000人。
so if so if they failed, what then? Well, the point is, is it goes to, comes down to this argument on the afternoon of, which comes to, rears its head really on the afternoon of Monday the 27th, when Halifax is saying, look, I've just, I've got these peace feeders going, you know, I've got these, had these talks with Bassanini, you know, he's saying he will intervene and Mussolini can be the kind of go-between between Hitler and us about a settled peace. And Churchill says, you just do not understand. You cannot do that. First of all, that goes against our alliance
所以如果他们失败了，那会怎样？嗯，重点是，这归结为那个下午的争论，这在5月27日星期一下午真正浮出水面，当时哈利法克斯说，看，我刚刚……我有了这些和平试探，你知道，我和巴斯塔尼尼进行了这些谈话，你知道，他说他会干预，墨索里尼可以成为希特勒和我们之间关于达成和平的中间人。丘吉尔说，你根本不明白。你不能那样做。首先，这违背了我们与法国的联盟
treaty with France. You know, you are not allowed to kind of, you know, you can't just sort of start negotiating behind someone's back when you haven't settled that with your ally first. So that's sort of perfidious to start off with. Then you've got the other problem. Once the door is ajar, it's slammed wide open. There's no way back. You're morally bankrupt. You've crossed a Rubicon of which there can be no return.
条约。你知道，你不被允许……你不能在没有先与盟友解决这个问题的情况下，就在别人背后开始谈判。所以这首先就是背信弃义。然后你有另一个问题。一旦门打开了一条缝，它就会被猛地完全推开。没有回头路了。你在道德上破产了。你越过了一条无法回头的卢比孔河。
And Halifax says, well, I just don't get it. I don't see why. I don't see why. Obviously, if the terms aren't good, then we won't pursue them. And judges are going, no, the moment you start talking terms, it's all over. You've got to understand this. I'm right on this. And Halifax gets really cross and just thinks he's being bloody minded and silly. And so this is before they know, this is before they know that Dunkirk evacuation has been a success. Yes, this is right at the
哈利法克斯说，嗯，我只是不明白。我不明白为什么。我不明白为什么。显然，如果条款不好，那我们就不会追求它们。丘吉尔说，不，你开始谈论条款的那一刻，一切就都结束了。你必须明白这一点。在这件事上我是对的。哈利法克斯变得非常生气，认为他只是在固执己见和愚蠢。所以这是在他们知道敦刻尔克撤离成功之前。是的，这是在
very beginning. So although it is launched on the afternoon of the Sunday the 26th, the first troops are not picked off until that day. So as the very, very first troops, and only 7,669 men are lifted off Dunkirk, off the Dunkirk beaches on that first day. You know, so the Germans are closing in and they're expecting it not to be more than, you know, 48 hours. OK, but just to be clear, Churchill's position is that
最开始。所以虽然它是在5月26日星期日下午发起的，但第一批部队直到那天下午才被接走。所以作为最初的部队，第一天只有7,669人从敦刻尔克海滩被撤离。你知道，所以德国人正在逼近，他们预计这不会超过48小时。好的，但要明确一点，丘吉尔的立场是
even if they don't get anyone off the beaches, Britain should fight on. Absolutely. And so what happens is that afternoon, Halifax loses his temper, which is very rare, and threatens to resign. Then there's a pause in the cabinet, and Churchill takes Halifax out into the garden of Number 10. No one knows what he's saying, what he says to him, but he puts a proverbial arm on his shoulder.
即使他们不能把任何人从海滩上救出来，英国也应该继续战斗。绝对是这样。所以那天下午发生的事情是，哈利法克斯发了脾气，这非常罕见，并威胁要辞职。然后内阁暂停了，丘吉尔把哈利法克斯带到了唐宁街10号的花园里。没人知道他在说什么，他对他说什么，但他把一只众所周知的胳膊搭在他的肩膀上。
They have a chat. And when they come back in, there's no more talk of resignation. But, you know, that first day is not particularly auspicious. I mean, 7,669 is, you know, when you're only going to be, probably the whole of Dunkirk
他们聊了聊。当他们回来时，再也没有人提辞职的事了。但是，你知道，第一天并不是特别吉利。我的意思是，7,669人，你知道，当你可能整个敦刻尔克
is going to fall in, you know, estimated 48 hours. You know, that is about 40,000 men, if you're lucky, probably less. You know, 40,000 was the kind of upper level of what was expected. They were kind of trumping that on one day. I mean, they got 65,000 off on one day. So later on in the week. So but what Churchill understands, and this is what what Halifax doesn't, because he doesn't have the same, quite the same geopolitical understanding that Churchill has, is that actually, Britain's strength does not lie in its army at all.
都要在预计48小时内陷落时。你知道，那大约是4万人，如果运气好的话，可能更少。你知道，4万人是预期的上限。他们在那一天就超过了这个数字。我的意思是，他们有一天救出了65,000人。所以是在那周晚些时候。但是丘吉尔明白的，而哈利法克斯不明白的，因为他没有丘吉尔那种地缘政治理解力，是实际上，英国的力量根本不在于它的军队。
The army has traditionally always been very, very small and is very, very small. You know, it's 10 divisions on the continent, you know, compared to 105 that the French have. And the division is the kind of unit by which we judge the sizes of armies in the 1940s, about 15,000, 16,000 men in a division. And he understands that the senior service is the Royal Navy, that they have the world's largest navy, that Britain has the world's largest merchant fleet, that we have access to around 85% of the world's merchant shipping, that we have a vast empire, that we're absolutely not alone,
军队传统上一直非常非常小，而且确实非常非常小。你知道，在欧洲大陆上有10个师，相比之下法国有105个师。师是我们在1940年代判断军队规模的单位，一个师大约有15,000到16,000人。他明白，主力军种是皇家海军，他们拥有世界上最大的海军，英国拥有世界上最大的商船队，我们拥有世界上约85%的商船运输渠道，我们拥有广阔的帝国，我们绝对不是孤军奋战，
that we can absolutely hold on, and that crossing the Channel and defeating an island nation is incredibly difficult. James, can I just jump in here? There are some historians, though, aren't there, who think that given all that you've said, that Britain has this great empire, that it has the fleet, that it has all these resources, all the rest of it,
我们可以绝对坚持下去，而且跨越海峡并击败一个岛国是极其困难的。詹姆斯，我能插一句吗？有一些历史学家，不是吗，他们认为鉴于你所说的一切，英国拥有这个伟大的帝国，拥有舰队，拥有所有这些资源，所有其他的一切，
wouldn't it have been better in the long run to have done a deal? No, I don't think this, but they think it. It would have been better to do a deal with Hitler or indeed not to have entered the war at all, to let Hitler and Stalin fight each other and knock each other out, as it were, and that the world would be, or that Britain would have been better placed at the end of the war if it had done Halifax's deal, if it had sort of husbanded its energies.
从长远来看，达成一项协议不是更好吗？不，我不这么认为，但他们是这么想的。与希特勒达成协议，或者干脆不参战，让希特勒和斯大林互相争斗并互相消耗，这会更好，如果英国在战争结束时达成哈利法克斯的协议，如果它节省了精力，它会处于更好的位置。
Now, you presumably think that is... But Dominic, can I also just just just to go back to the question i was right at the beginning which which is what would the deal have been because the question of whether the deal would would have been you know in in any way kind of bearable surely is dependent on what that deal would have been yeah well let me let me i mean they're both connected i mean the deal would have been a bad one for britain they would have lost a number of properties almost certainly gibraltar, Malta, lots of overseas territories, access to the Suez Canal, which would have been catastrophic for India,
现在，你大概认为那是……但是多米尼克，我能回到我一开始提出的问题吗，那就是协议会是什么样子？因为协议是否在任何方面可以忍受，肯定取决于协议会是什么。是的，嗯，让我……我的意思是，它们都是相关的。我的意思是，这对英国来说将是一个糟糕的协议。他们几乎肯定会失去许多财产，直布罗陀、马耳他、许多海外领土、苏伊士运河的通行权，这对印度来说将是灾难性的，
obviously, which still remains a jewel in the crown at that point. Access to the Far East, of course, the collapse of the Far East hasn't happened at that point, and that is a massive source of resources out there. Global humiliation. And the problem is that Hitler can't be trusted at all. That's been proved. So you don't know. You might have a deal
显然，印度在那时仍然是皇冠上的明珠。当然还有通往远东的通道，远东的崩溃在那时还没有发生，那是那里巨大的资源来源。全球性的羞辱。问题是希特勒根本不可信。这一点已经被证明了。所以你不知道。你可能在
in June 1940, but whether that stands is extremely unlikely. Large part of massive disarmament would have been a key point which would have left them vulnerable to invasion later on. It would have been catastrophic. Churchill himself says, doesn't he, that we would have had to hand over the fleet and we'd have mostly put in charge.
1940年6月达成了一项协议，但它是否能维持下去极不可能。大规模的裁军将是一个关键点，这将使他们在以后容易受到入侵。那将是灾难性的。丘吉尔自己说，不是吗，我们不得不交出舰队，我们会被置于控制之下。
Yeah, I think that bad. I he might not have had they might not have had to hand over the fleet. But but it's a possibility. You know, you're not going to bet on that, are you? I mean, the point of the point is once you're once you're negotiating about whether you keep the fleet or not, it's all over. You know, you've lost so terribly. It's about a reduction of everything that Britain stands for. All right, well, let's go back to the meetings. So in the sort of popular imagination,
是的，我认为那么糟糕。他可能……他们可能不必交出舰队。但这是一种可能性。你知道，你不会拿那个打赌，对吧？我的意思是，重点是，一旦你开始谈判是否保留舰队，一切就都结束了。你知道，你输得太惨了。这是关于英国所代表的一切的缩减。好吧，让我们回到会议。所以在大众的想象中，
Churchill prevails against the sort of Tory old guard, so Halifax and Chamberlain. But my impression is that that's completely wrong, that Chamberlain's is the key voice and that Chamberlain has kind of been maligned by popular history, which paints him as this sort of archipelago. Whereas in the crucial meeting,
丘吉尔战胜了保守党的老卫队，也就是哈利法克斯和张伯伦。但我的印象是这完全错了，张伯伦是关键的声音，而且张伯伦被大众历史所诋毁，大众历史把他描绘成这种……而在关键的会议上，
it's Chamberlain, isn't it, who says, no, no, Churchill is right. We must back Churchill. We must fight on Hitler. Can't be trusted. Yeah. I mean, we're very fortunate that we have verbatim accounts of every single word that's said in these cabinet meetings and they're absolutely fascinating and um you know John Lukacs's book um Five Days in May is is or Five Days in London whatever it's called I mean he's just completely brilliant on this it's really vivid it's incredibly compelling and what you see is that Churchill does it starts to
是张伯伦，不是吗，他说，不，不，丘吉尔是对的。我们必须支持丘吉尔。我们必须继续战斗。希特勒不可信。是的。我的意思是，我们非常幸运，我们有这些内阁会议中说的每一个字的逐字记录，它们绝对令人着迷，而且……你知道约翰·卢卡奇的书《五月五日》或者叫什么名字，我的意思是他在这一点上非常出色，非常生动，非常引人入胜，你看到的是丘吉尔确实开始
kind of stick up for Churchill on um Chamberlain rather starts to stick up for Churchill on that Monday um and I think is one of the one of the reasons you know I think the main reason why Halifax doesn't resign is because of the conversation that happens in the garden that we don't know about but it's also because it's clear that Chamberlain is also starting to inch with towards towards Churchill on this one he kind of keeps out of it to a large extent it's also because it's clear that Chamberlain is also starting to inch with towards Churchill on this one he kind of keeps out of it to a large extent it's really a back and forth between Halifax and Churchill but on the following day Tuesday he absolutely does and he says no no no you you know Winston I'm paraphrasing but Winston's correct you know you can't deal with
开始支持丘吉尔……张伯伦开始在那周一支持丘吉尔，我认为这是哈利法克斯没有辞职的主要原因之一，因为我们在花园里进行的谈话我们不知道，但这也是因为很明显张伯伦也开始在这件事上向丘吉尔靠拢。他很大程度上置身事外。这实际上是哈利法克斯和丘吉尔之间的来回拉锯，但在第二天，周二，他绝对做到了，他说不，不，不，你……你知道温斯顿，我是在转述，但温斯顿是对的，你知道你不能和
these guys you know I'm with Churchill on this and since that since Attlee and Greenwood don't really they do have a vote, but they don't effectively have a vote in this. It is a three-way power tussle between Halifax, Chamberlain and Churchill. And Chamberlain and Halifax are really, really tight. I mean, they're very, very good friends. They've been colleagues for many years.
这些人打交道，你知道我在这件事上支持丘吉尔。既然艾德礼和格林伍德并没有真正……他们确实有投票权，但他们实际上没有投票权。这是哈利法克斯、张伯伦和丘吉尔之间的三方权力斗争。张伯伦和哈利法克斯真的非常非常紧密。我的意思是，他们是非常好的朋友。他们多年来一直是同事。
They're absolutely cut from the same sort of political cloth in terms of their outlook and all the rest of it. And you would, you know, just from personality point of view, you would expect probably Chamberlain to side with Halifax. Again, because he doesn't have that kind of global geopolitical understanding that Churchill does. And yet he doesn't. And, you know, that is a moment of greatness that's perhaps overstating it.
他们在政治观点和所有其他方面绝对是同一种人。而且你，你知道，仅仅从个性的角度来看，你可能会期望张伯伦站在哈利法克斯一边。同样，因为他没有丘吉尔那种全球地缘政治理解力。然而他没有。而且，你知道，那是一个伟大的时刻，也许说得太过了。
But, you know, Chamberlain is a total lad in 1940. I mean, you know, once he resigns, he's brilliant. You heard it here first. Do you think that Chamberlain does this because he's had dealings of how Hitler just doesn't keep his word? I mean, he's kind of bringing his personal experience here. Yeah, unquestionably. But I do think, generally speaking, I think Chamberlain is much maligned.
但是，你知道，张伯伦在1940年是一个了不起的人。我的意思是，你知道，一旦他辞职，他就很出色。你在这里第一次听到。你认为张伯伦这样做是因为他有希特勒如何不守信用的经历吗？我的意思是，他在这里带入了他个人的经验。是的，毫无疑问。但我确实认为，总的来说，我认为张伯伦被严重诋毁了。
I mean, you wouldn't have all those Spitfires and Hurricanes in 1940 to win the Battle of Britain if it hadn't been for Chamberlain when he was Chancellor back in 1935. As Churchill says when Chamberlain dies, doesn't he, later in the year? He gives a very moving thrannity on him. Okay, so moving on to what really is the kind of
我的意思是，如果不是因为张伯伦在1935年担任财政大臣时所做的一切，你就不会在1940年拥有所有那些喷火式和飓风式战斗机来赢得不列颠战役。正如丘吉尔在张伯伦去世时所说的那样，不是吗，在今年晚些时候？他对他发表了一篇非常感人的悼词。好的，那么转向真正是那种
the key question that everybody has asked. So just I just quote a question from splendidly named I.R. Baboon. So so we've got the army out. We're fighting on. And I.R. Baboon asks, would Operation Sea Lion, the Nazi plan for the invasion of Britain, have been successful, even if the Luftwaffe had control over the skies because there's still the royal navy which still hasn't been beaten so the question is and i i kind of know what the answer is if i'm going to answer anyway basically how decisive is the battle of britain the battle of britain is incredibly decisive um it it well first of all to first first answer the question question is no they couldn't have got across.
每个人都问的关键问题。所以我引用一个名字很棒的I.R.狒狒的问题。所以我们把军队撤出来了。我们正在继续战斗。I.R.狒狒问，海狮行动，纳粹入侵英国的计划，会成功吗，即使德国空军控制了天空，因为还有皇家海军，它还没有被击败。所以问题是，我大概知道答案，如果我要回答的话，总之，不列颠战役有多决定性？不列颠战役极其决定性。嗯，它……首先，回答这个问题，答案是不，他们不可能跨越海峡。
I mean, not a hope in hell. I mean, just not a hope. You think how much jeopardy there is in 1944 when the Allies are going across to Normandy. You know, the intelligence picture has to be absolutely spot on. We've got to keep them guessing right up to the last minute. You know, we have to have overwhelming air superiority over the entire swathe of Northwest Europe.
我的意思是，一点希望都没有。我的意思是，根本没有希望。你想想1944年盟军跨越到诺曼底时有多大的风险。你知道，情报画面必须绝对准确。我们必须让他们一直猜到最后一分钟。你知道，我们必须在整个西北欧地区拥有压倒性的空中优势。
You know, we have to have overwhelming naval superiority as well well as well as firepower and all the rest of it you know all those things have to be met before you can even consider attempting a cross-channel invasion i mean germany doesn't have remotely any one of those those so why is the battle of britain decisive then because it it consigns germany to a long attritional war that it can't afford to fight. And it makes the one thing that is absolutely guaranteed the moment Hitler comes into power in 1933, that there is going to be the God almighty ding dongs of ding dongs against the Soviet Union at some point. Now, when this happens and what the conditions are and who actually wins is up for grabs in certainly in 1933. But the point is, is that, you know, Hitler was originally planning for an invasion of Soviet
你知道，我们必须拥有压倒性的海军优势以及火力等等，你知道，在你可以考虑尝试跨海峡入侵之前，所有这些事情都必须满足。我的意思是，德国根本没有其中任何一个。那么为什么不列颠战役是决定性的呢？因为它把德国推向了一场它打不起的长期消耗战。它使希特勒1933年上台时绝对保证的一件事成为必然，那就是在某个时候会与苏联发生一场惊天动地的冲突。现在，当这种情况发生时，条件是什么，谁真正赢了，在1933年肯定还是未知数。但重点是，你知道，希特勒最初计划入侵苏联
Union in roughly 1943, possibly 1944. The idea is not to fight a global conflict. It's to fight a series of small conflicts, small, short, sharp conflicts, which Germany can win comprehensively. I mean, the whole German way of war is about annihilating your enemy completely. And he's hustled into an invasion of the soviet union before germany is ready i mean the the luftwaffe is weaker in june in the third week of june 1941 which is where operation barbarossa is launched and it was on the 10th of may 1940 and a large part of that is because there's catastrophic losses they suffer in the battle of breton but but it's also you know they're just they're just not ready for a conflict on that scale.
大约在1943年，可能是1944年。这个想法不是打一场全球冲突。而是打一系列小规模的冲突，小规模、短暂、激烈的冲突，德国可以全面获胜。我的意思是，整个德国的战争方式就是彻底消灭你的敌人。他被匆忙推入了一场在德国准备好之前对苏联的入侵。我的意思是，德国空军在1941年6月的第三周，也就是巴巴罗萨行动发起时，比1940年5月10日要弱，很大程度上是因为他们在不列颠战役中遭受了灾难性的损失，但这也是因为……他们只是没有为那种规模的冲突做好准备。
And they have to do that because Britain is still in the war and hovering in the shadows is the United States with its huge manpower and industrialisation and all the rest of it. And he knows he has to beat the West
他们必须这样做，因为英国仍在战争中，而美国带着其巨大的人力和工业化等等在阴影中徘徊。他知道他必须击败西方
to win the war. And he doesn't want to be fighting on two fronts for any longer than he absolutely has to. But to stick to the Battle of Britain, because most people's sense of the Battle britain is that this is the the key you know if if britain loses the battle of britain then we get invaded but you're saying that even if the battle even if we lose the battle of britain there's no prospect of a successful german invasion of britain in summer of 1940? No, the danger...
才能赢得战争。他不想在任何比他绝对必须更长的时间里在两条战线上作战。但回到不列颠战役，因为大多数人对不列颠战役的感觉是这是关键，你知道，如果英国输掉了不列颠战役，那么我们就会被入侵，但你是说即使不列颠战役输了，1940年夏天德国成功入侵英国的前景也不存在？不，危险……
I mean, say the RAF is... Say they do successfully invade, then obviously that's catastrophe. Had we kind of sued for peace on the 27th, started opening peace feelers on the 27th of May or 28th of May or something, and Dunkirk's a failure, then they wouldn't have needed to invade Great Britain. No, you know, when Dunkirk's a failure, then they wouldn't
我的意思是，假设英国皇家空军是……假设他们确实成功入侵了，那么显然那是灾难。如果我们确实在27日求和，在5月27日或28日左右开始开启和平试探，而敦刻尔克失败了，那么他们就不需要入侵英国了。不，你知道，当敦刻尔克失败时，他们就不需要
have needed to invade Great Britain. No, but I'm saying with the Battle of Britain, because it's specifically, we have this idea that the Battle of Britain is where, you know, never so much, by so many to so few. This isn't quite the pivot that most people traditionally think then, is what you're saying. Well, on paper, there is no reason to throw in the towel. And I don't think churchill would have certainly let it let it happen even if the ref had been defeated but my point is is that the rf is such a long way from being defeated that hitler's failure to defeat britain in 1940
入侵英国了。不，但我说的是不列颠战役，因为它是专门的，我们有这种想法，不列颠战役是，你知道，从来没有这么多人为这么少的人做过这么多事。那么这不是大多数人传统上认为的转折点，你是这个意思吗？嗯，在纸面上，没有理由认输。而且我不认为丘吉尔肯定会让它发生，即使英国皇家空军被击败了，但我的观点是，英国皇家空军距离被击败还很远，以至于希特勒在1940年未能击败英国
is that is the decisive the decisive battle as it turns out in the second world war above all because it ensures that britain carries on fighting And it consigns Germany to a long attritional battle, which ultimately they can't win. I mean, you know, if you just think about this, you know, if you think about the middle of June 1941, Nazi Germany has one enemy, Great Britain, albeit Great Britain plus dominions and empire. Fast forward to six months to, you know, middle of December 1941, it's got three enemies. It's got Great Britain plus Empire and Dominions. It's got United States of America and the Soviet Union. I mean, it just it is simply not going to win. The strategic earthquake of the Second World War that are twofold. First is, you know, the Japanese attacks in December and early
是第二次世界大战中事实上的决定性战役，最重要的是因为它确保了英国继续战斗。它把德国推向了一场长期的消耗战，他们最终无法获胜。我的意思是，你知道，如果你只是想想这个，你知道，如果你想想1941年6月中旬，纳粹德国有一个敌人，大英帝国，尽管是大英帝国加上自治领和帝国。快进六个月到，你知道，1941年12月中旬，它有三个敌人。它有大英帝国加上帝国和自治领。它有美利坚合众国和苏联。我的意思是，它只是……它根本不可能赢。第二次世界大战的战略地震是双重的。首先是，你知道，日本在1941年12月和1942年初的袭击。那是第二个。第一次重大战略地震是1940年5月和6月法国的陷落。我认为其他一切几乎都是预先注定的。詹姆斯，让我带你回到入侵。所以，我的意思是，汤姆和我谈论过这些书，你知道，纳粹英国，海狮行动发生了，罗伯特·哈里斯。我受不了它们。所有这些东西。
part of December 1941 and early part of 1942. That's the second one. The first major strategic earthquake is the fall of France in May and June 1940. Everything else, I think, is pretty much predetermined. James, let me take you back to the invasion. So, I mean, Tom and I have talked about these books, you know, Nazi Britain, Operation Sea Lion happened, Robert Harris. And I can't bear them. All these sort of stuff.
现在，你真的在说德国入侵没有现实的前景吗？我的意思是，所有这些在我看来是一个非常大的主张，考虑到我们不知道即使是小规模的德国登陆对士气等的影响。你知道，我们不知道士气是否会崩溃。我们不知道德国人会深入内陆多远等等。但你真的在说你确定这永远不会发生，从来都不现实吗？还有一个额外的问题，侧面问题是，希特勒真的想这样做吗？你认为他真的曾经签署过海狮行动吗？
Now, are you genuinely saying there was no realistic prospects of a German invasion? I mean, all that strikes me is that's a very big claim to make, given that we don't know the effect on morale and so on, of even a small German landing. You know, we don't know whether morale would have crumbled. We don't know how far the Germans would have got inland and so on and so forth. But are you really saying you're certain that this was just never going to happen, never realistic? And an additional sort of question, side question is, did Hitler even actually want to do it? Was he really ever signed up to Operation Sea Lion, do you think?
嗯，希特勒在战争中做出了一些非常疯狂的决定，必须说他不是最健全的军事头脑，但即使是他也认识到，没有空中控制权，甚至连机会都没有。即使他们获得了空中控制权，让我们面对现实吧，你必须承认在不列颠战役中，138个机场中只有一个被摧毁超过48小时，所以这完全是……无论你怎么看，这都是一个彻底的失败。但除此之外，还有大约14个轰炸机中队准备好用化学武器投放到任何入侵舰队上。认为我们不会知道
Well, Hitler made some pretty crazy decisions in the war and was not the soundest of military military minds it has to be said but even he recognized that without air without control of the skies there wasn't even a chance even if they had got control of the skies and let's face it you have to accept that in the battle of breton out of 138 airfields only one was knocked out for more than 48 hours so it was just a completely you know it's an abject failure every which way you look at it but on top of that there's something like 14 bomber command squadrons ready with chemical weapons to drop on any invasion fleet. The idea that we wouldn't know
入侵在开始后24小时内，你知道，在它开始前24小时内，简直是荒谬的。而且他们没有任何登陆艇。他们有一些他们开发的这种渡轮，它们相当，你知道，它们绝对是糟糕的
that the invasion is launching, you know, within 24 hours of it being started is, 24 hours before it being started is just ridiculous. And that they don't have any landing craft. They've got a few of these sort of ferries that they've developed, which are kind of pretty, you know, they're absolutely woeful
而且根本不适合跨越海峡。其余的是莱茵河驳船，而且大多数是机动的。所以他们必须做的是，他们有一艘机动的拖着两艘非机动的驳船。我的意思是，你能想象1940年进行大规模入侵还有比这更烂的事情吗？
and completely not suitable for going across the Channel at all. The rest of them are Rhine River barges, and then most of them are motorised. So what they're having to do is they're having one motorised one towing two unmotorised barges. I mean, can you imagine anything more crap than that for a major invasion in 1940?
我的意思是，它根本行不通。而且你拥有世界上最大的海军，他们完全明白，他们完全理解在军事上英国比在欧洲大陆的失败所暗示的要强大得多。所以等等，詹姆斯，那不是提出了一个问题吗，为什么丘吉尔会说，我们将在海滩上战斗，我们将在登陆坡道上战斗，如果他知道没有现实的前景
I mean, it's simply not going to work. And you've got the world's largest navy, and they completely understand that they completely get that that that militarily they have britain is far stronger than defeat on the continent and the evacuation of dunkirk would would suggest so hold on james doesn't that then raise the question why does churchill then his, we will fight them on the beaches, we'll fight them on the landing ramp, if he knows there's no realistic prospect
他们会出现在海滩上？因为这完全是关于……嗯，因为他知道这一点，但这看起来也不太……你知道，当你有成群的纳粹飞机飞过来时，它看起来仍然相当吓人。而且他还明白，每个人都需要团结起来，意识到有一个巨大的威胁，非常非常认真地对待它，不要以任何方式对它掉以轻心，除了有一个真正的威胁，所有人团结起来，这就是
that they're going to be on the beaches? Because that's all about, well, because he knows that, but it also doesn't seem quite, you know, when you've got hordes of Nazi planes coming over, it still seems pretty intimidating. And he also understands that what everyone needs to do is come together, kind of realise that there is a big threat take it really really seriously not be kind of lackadaisical about it in any way whatsoever except there is a real threat and all pulled together and that's
发生的事情。现在我知道外面有愤世嫉俗者，所以会说，嗯，仍然有人被谋杀，有黑市商人和在闪电战中闯入房屋偷东西的人，但这个国家确实团结起来了，自由世界在那个例子中团结起来了。你知道，很多很多美国人也过来了。这就是丘吉尔加强言辞的另一个重要原因，因为，你知道，他非常清楚
exactly what happened now i know there are cynics out there so go yeah well there were people still being murdered there was black marketeers and people breaking into houses in the blitz and stealing stuff but but the the country did come together the free world came together in that instance. You know, lots and lots of Americans coming over as well. And that's the other big reasons why Churchill was ramping up the rhetoric because, you know, he knew perfectly well
罗斯福最糟糕的噩梦是被纳粹德国征服或统治的英国。你知道，突然间大西洋不再是他们那种孤立的、非军事化的世界观的巨大屏障了。而且，你知道，这完全是为了鼓励美国人加强战争制造等等，并站在他们一边，你知道，这就是为什么我们需要我们的40艘驱逐舰和所有这些东西，因为
that Roosevelt's worst nightmare was a Britain conquered or dominated by Nazi Germany. You know, suddenly the Atlantic is not the great barrier that it once was to their insular kind of non-militaristic approach to the world. And, you know know that's all about encouraging the Americans to kind of beef up war manufacturing and all the rest of it and come in on their side and you know that's why we need our 40 destroyers and all this kind of stuff because
你知道，其中大部分在1944年最终变成了近海的废铁。我的意思是，你知道，所以这……你知道，它们从来没有多大用处……但这不是重点。我的意思是，你知道，有很多美国观察员过来，所以他们想做的是说，你知道，这真的很严重，这就是威胁，这就是如果我们不努力我们所面临的情况，没有任何自满的余地。然而这些美国观察员会过来，像……这样的人，他们后来在战争中成为了空军指挥官。像图伊·斯帕茨这样的人？
you know most of which ended up as kind of breakers offshore in 1944 I mean you know so it's it's you know they were never much use uh um but that's not the point i mean you know there are lots of american observers coming over and so what they wanted to do is say you know this is really serious this is the threat that this is what we're looking at if if we don't pull our finger out there's no room for complacency whatsoever and yet these american observers would come over people like um to his spots and stuff who ended up becoming a you know air commander later on in the war. People like Toohey Spots?
你知道，他们过来报告，图伊·斯帕茨，是的。那是一个真正的美国名字吗？嗯，图伊是他的绰号。他真名叫卡尔。但斯帕茨是他的姓。但S-P-A-A-T-Z。而且，你知道，他报告说，
You know, they're coming over and reporting, Toohey Spots, yeah. Is that a genuine American name? Well, Toohey was his nickname. He was really called Carl. But Spots was his surname. But S-P-A-A-T-Z. And, you know, he was reporting back going,
我看不出德国空军怎么可能赢。你知道，英国完全没问题。而这正是我们想让他说的。所以我们，我想，在40分钟内完成了整个波斯历史。我们花了比那更长的时间来做大约三周的事情。所以我们可能应该开始走向结束了。但我们经历了敦刻尔克。我们经历了不列颠战役。
I can't see how the Luftwaffe could possibly win. You know, Britain's absolutely fine. And that's exactly what we want him to say. So we did, I think, the entire history of Persia in 40 minutes. We've taken longer than that to do about three weeks. So we should probably start moving to the end. But we've had Dunkirk. We've had the Battle of Britain.
当然，1940年英国历史上发生的另一件著名事件是闪电战。你认为政府和普通民众是否意识到不列颠战役的胜利意味着大规模轰炸是不可避免的？这是他们等待发生的事情，还是这让他们感到惊讶？嗯，不，因为大规模轰炸发生在不列颠战役期间。所以它在1940年9月7日星期六发起。从战术上讲，它完全没有任何意义。如果他们声明的目标是试图摧毁英国皇家空军，他们最好还是瞄准机场。但问题是，他们没有足够的轰炸机来完成这项工作。
Of course, the other famous event in British history that happens in 1940 is the Blitz. Do you think that people in both government and the general population have an appreciation of the fact that victory in the Battle of Britain means that large-scale bombing is kind of inevitable? Is it something that they're waiting to happen or does it come as a surprise? Well, no, because the large-scale bombing happens in the middle of the Battle of Britain. So that launched on Saturday the 7th of September 1940. And tactically, it makes absolutely no sense whatsoever. If their stated aim is to try and destroy the RAF, they're much better off targeting airfields. But the problem is, is they just don't have enough bombers to do the job.
我的意思是，所以不列颠战役仍在进行中。我的意思是，你知道，我们距离成为不列颠战役日，即9月15日，还有一周零一天，那是萨迪的生日，对吧？1940年。我深爱的妻子。是的。所以它只是，它开始发生了。
I mean, so the Battle of Britain is still going on. I mean, you know, we're still a week and a day away from what becomes Battle of Britain Day, the 15th of September, which is Sadie's birthday, right? 1940. My beloved wife. Yeah. So it's just, it's starting to happen.
那是对轰炸柏林的报复。所以英国皇家空军在德国空军故意轰炸伦敦之前，四次轰炸了柏林。人们总是说那是一次蓄意的尝试。那是真的吗？这是一种试图激怒德国人停止轰炸机场的蓄意策略吗？那是真的还是假的？
And that is in retaliation to the bombing of Berlin. So the RAF bombs Berlin before, four times before Luftwaffe deliberately bombs London. And it's always said that that is a deliberate attempt. Is that true? That this is a deliberate strategy to try and annoy the Germans into stopping bombing the airfields? Is that true or not?
不，这实际上是为了展示他们能做到，并展示他们不仅仅是坐以待毙，他们仍在游戏中，他们向德国人展示他们没有赢，他们仍在游戏中，他们向德国人展示，你知道，他们没有赢，英国轰炸机将会过来。
No, it's really to show that they can do it and to show that they are not just sitting back and taking it, that they're still in the game, that they're showing Germans that they haven't won, that they're still in the game, that they're showing Germans that, you know, they haven't won, that British bombers are going to come over
不，这实际上是为了表明他们能够做到，表明他们并没有坐以待毙，他们仍然在参与这场博弈，他们向德国人展示德国人并没有获胜，他们仍然在参与这场博弈，他们向德国人展示，你知道，他们并没有获胜，英国轰炸机将会飞过来
and this is what you can expect. I mean, you know, you have to also, one has to remember that despite the sort of terrible scenes in the East End, terrible scenes in Southampton, Liverpool, of course, Coventry in November 1940 and all the rest of it. I mean, you know, it is very, very, very small beer indeed compared to what the Germans are going to receive later on in the war. I mean, you know, the total tonnage of bombs that are dropped on London in the Blitz between September the 7th, 1940 and the middle of
这就是你可以预期的。我的意思是，你知道，你还必须记住，尽管东区、南安普敦、利物浦，当然还有1940年11月的考文垂等地发生了可怕的场景，但与德国人在战争后期将要遭受的轰炸相比，这些简直是小巫见大巫。我的意思是，你知道，在1940年9月7日到1941年年中期间，伦敦在闪电战中遭受的炸弹总吨位是1.8万吨。
May 1941 is 18,000 tonnes. I mean, you know, that is, I mean, the Allies drop 197,000 tonnes in nine weeks on France alone in the run up to D-Day. So, you know, that is the kind of comparison we're talking about. But the interesting thing is, you know, the Germans just don't have enough of anything to do what they're trying to do in the summer of 1940 to defeat Britain. The conclusion that I would come to from listening to you is that basically Germany have lost the war even then. That Germany have almost, in a sense, Germany have lost the war from the very beginning. I mean, you're painting a picture in which it's actually very hard listening to what you say about Britain's great strengths, its supply network, its allies, its dominions
1941年5月是1.8万吨。我的意思是，你知道，盟军在诺曼底登陆前的九周内，仅在法国就投下了19.7万吨炸弹。所以，你知道，这就是我们所说的对比。但有趣的是，你知道，德国人在1940年夏天根本没有足够的资源来完成他们试图击败英国的目标。我听了你的话得出的结论是，基本上德国在那时就已经输掉了战争。从某种意义上说，德国从一开始就输了。我的意思是，你描绘了一幅画面，听你讲述英国的强大实力、供应网络、盟友、自治领，
and so on, Germany's weakness, Germany, they don't have enough to do this, they don't have enough to do that. In a way, haven't they lost already? Is that not the conclusion that you would come to? Which in that case, if that's obvious to you, how come it's not obvious to everybody else at the time? Well, I mean, it is to a certain extent. I mean, Churchill says, you know, Hitler knows he must defeat Britain or lose the war. And, you know, that's exactly what happens. I mean, I think you can say and argue and argue convincingly that it is definitely all over for Germany by November 1941.
等等，以及德国的弱点，德国没有足够的能力做这个，没有足够的能力做那个。从某种程度上说，他们不是已经输了吗？这难道不是你会得出的结论吗？如果是这样的话，如果这对你来说很明显，为什么当时其他人没有意识到呢？嗯，我的意思是，在某种程度上是意识到的。丘吉尔说，你知道，希特勒知道他必须击败英国，否则就会输掉战争。而且，你知道，事实正是如此。我的意思是，我认为你可以说，而且有说服力地论证，到1941年11月，德国的一切肯定都结束了。
When Barbarossa, the invasion of Soviet Union, has failed. I don't think there's any way back. But I also don't think there was a huge amount of chance of that working either. The odds were stacked against Barbarossa being successful, despite the kind of overwhelming victories in the initial weeks and the kind of sort of envelopments of vast Soviet armies and all the rest of it, although it looked very bleak if you were stalin you know and there was the day of panic i think it was the 16th of october 1941 where you know they're all fleeing moscow and burning papers and all the rest of it even so that was still a huge stretch because of the huge logistical chains that were being put on the germans and all the rest of it but it was made more you know the the reason it's
当巴巴罗萨行动，即入侵苏联失败时。我不认为还有回头路。但我也不认为那次行动有多大成功的机会。尽管在最初的几周里取得了压倒性的胜利，包围了庞大的苏联军队等等，但巴巴罗萨行动成功的几率很小。如果你是斯大林，情况看起来非常严峻，我想那是1941年10月16日的恐慌日，你知道，他们都在逃离莫斯科，烧毁文件等等。即便如此，由于德国人面临的巨大后勤压力，这仍然是一个巨大的挑战。但之所以
unlikely to succeed is because they've been hustled into it. And the reason they've been hustled into it and launching it in the middle of June 1941 is because they've lost the Battle of Britain. And the whole point is, OK, well, what are we going to do now? Britain is still in the game. America waiting in the wings of all this industrial might clearly siding. You know, even if it's not actually in the war, it's certainly siding materialistically with Britain and the Allies. You know, so we need to knock Britain out, but we're not strong enough to do that. So we're going to have to go and get the wealth of the Soviet Union, and then we can turn back and face Britain.
不太可能成功，是因为他们是被仓促推入其中的。他们之所以被仓促推入并在1941年6月中旬发动进攻，是因为他们输掉了不列颠战役。重点是，好吧，我们现在该怎么办？英国还在游戏中。美国在这一切工业力量的背后等待着，显然站在了这一边。你知道，即使它没有真正参战，它在物质上也肯定站在英国和盟军一边。所以，我们需要击败英国，但我们没有足够的力量做到这一点。因此，我们必须去获取苏联的财富，然后我们才能回过头来对付英国。
So 1940 is actually the beginning of the end. Yeah, I think you could, yeah. Well, I think we've seen off the Germans, Tom. I think we have. Let's put them in their place. I think that's about it for today's The Rest Is History. James, thank you so much. I've been waiting ages for somebody to come on
所以1940年实际上是终结的开始。是的，我想你可以这么说。好吧，我想我们已经击退了德国人，汤姆。我想我们做到了。让我们让他们各归其位。我想今天的《历史余韵》就到这里了。詹姆斯，非常感谢你。我等了很久才有人来
and show Tom precisely how you do this podcast. And I thought it would bite all the more if it came from his younger brother. So it's great that you've come on and put him in his place. Well, we could do an episode on Elder and younger brothers. Do you know what I was actually thinking, Tom? That would be a great subject. Harry and Wills.
向汤姆展示你究竟是如何做这个播客的。我觉得如果由他的弟弟来做，效果会更好。所以你来这里让他各归其位真是太好了。好吧，我们可以做一期关于哥哥和弟弟的节目。你知道我其实在想什么吗，汤姆？那会是一个很棒的主题。哈里和威廉。
So much to play with. Well, I'm absolutely thrilled to be on and it's been great fun and I never need any second invitation to talk about 1940. That's to be said. Jolly good. Well, and also, if people haven't had enough of you, there are also 300 episodes of We Have Ways of Making You Talk. That's a hell of a lot of tanks, Tom.
有很多可以发挥的地方。好吧，我非常高兴能参加，这非常有趣，而且我永远不需要第二次邀请来谈论1940年。这是肯定的。太好了。而且，如果大家还没听够你的内容，还有300集的《我们有办法让你开口》。那可是相当多的坦克啊，汤姆。
There's a lot of Second World War. A lot of Second World War. Thanks so much, bro. It's been sensational. It's been great fun. Thank you. And we will be back next week with a bonus live episode on wednesday so do please put that in your diaries and we will see you then goodbye for now
有很多关于第二次世界大战的内容。很多关于第二次世界大战的内容。非常感谢，兄弟。这太精彩了。非常有趣。谢谢。我们下周三会回来，带来一期额外的直播节目，所以请务必在日记中记下来，我们到时候见，暂时再见。
thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史余韵》。如需额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。